- At one point when I was 13,
in Juvenile Hall in Sylmar,
I asked myself to put in work,
to get where you're at,
I guess, pretty, got to
put in work to, you know,
be where you want to be from
your neighborhood, whatever.
But, as I see things today,
as a juvenile to an adult,
I feel for you youngsters today.
You know, looking at life,
never been in County jail,
never been to prison,
just doing time in juvenile hall.
Everyone's your enemy, but
as soon as the time flies,
and you get to be 18 years
old and hit County jail
lot of people are going
to guide you and tell you,
'Hey, this is what you gotta do'.
'Hey, watch out for these people'.
You know what I mean?
You know, you're going to
hear different stories.
You're gonna hear different opinions.
What you feel is right for
your best, is right for you,
you put to conclusion. Common sense.
Something that you can get off of,
not something that leads
in the wrong direction.
Because believe me nowadays,
people tell you anything,
just to get you where you want to go.
But, when you hit that County jail,
and have that L looking at life,
you know, this is no joke, man.
You're not getting out, you know.
Or let's just say, that you
do got some time on you.
arm and a leg, 17, 18 years,
but you are getting out.
You don't want to be in there,
and get more time and get life
and then never getting out.
It's sad because, hey,
people up there already double sentence,
life sentence, never getting out.
So they could put in
the work all they want,
but for someone, like ourselves,
that have a date to come home, be smart.
Don't be stupid, man.
You know, as far as we're
going to County jail, you know
all around flaw, we stay with our unit.
You know what I mean?
The blacks, others, Asians, the woodpile,
you know what I mean?
You know, us, Hispanics,
Surenos, Southsiders;
mandatory workout, Monday to Friday.
On Saturday and Sunday, day off.
What I did, in juvenile hall?
Oh man! I love playing
handball. Handball all day.
Tweety! She rocks in the
tree top, all day long.
I'm playing my money. Get my
money, work out, bus down.
As we got older, County jail, same thing.
Playing hit the prison.
Whoa!
With the big boys and in prison,
get that little small ball.
Like what the hell, man?
Man, I'm learning, but at the same time,
on a high level yard, for like I said,
to a level three, to level four,
to the hall, to the shoe
program, to the 180 to 280.
I'm telling you, the 180 and
280, is something just...
You're not, you're not
there with Disneyland.
You're not there at camp Snoopy.
You're there on a high
level yoh of lifers.
People that have been doing time for 35.
I mean, if I came in
what, 45 years bend down.
What I'm trying to tell
you people is that,
when you go to a high level
yard, don't be stupid.
Be smart about it.
If you have a date to come
home, that'd be a blessing.
But if you don't have a date,
I guess you just do what you gotta do.
But I mean nowadays, people
that are so-called active,
and go to a main line, end
up "where did the homie go?"
"Oh, he PC."
PC?
What the fuck is that?
Because, if you can't be who
you say you're going to be,
and you want to go and
fake the funk in prison,
and they put you on blast,
and then you're like,
"I don't want to fight you."
You want to fight?
That is a no, no.
You gotta be down for anything, my boy.
And then, can I gel?
Yeah, talon talos, full body shots.
In prison? Bring your shank.
What the fuck?
You gonna learn?
Damn! You know what I mean?
You think that defending yourself,
to learn from your mistakes,
but what the shank?
Cause you not supposed to make a mistake,
and I'm gonna make sure you learn.
But guess what?
You won't go man down,
"Help me.
I'm bleeding."
Nope, you can't do that.
What do you mean?
Tell you what, get Folgers.
"Folgers on the...?"
Yeah, cause they're, you know, shanks?
In, out, in, out.
I've seen people getting stuff, like damn!
Lines 10 times.
You can't go man down.
Go to cell.
Hey, homie's good, he's good.
Wow!
Shocked like damn!
That's a soldier.
That is a gladiator.
When you learn, from right people,
I'm hoping that when
you guys go to prison,
that it molds you to be somebody.
Not to be, man, that fooling nobody.
(inaudible) He talks a lot of shit.
Today in life, make it as
what you want to make of it.
But just because you're in prison,
learn from the fucking mistake.
In high level yard they tell you,
"Ain't no poor little homie over here."
Go to school, or get a job.
All that "Oh I got all
this time on my hands."
No, no, no, no, no, no
program time, homie.
They have a thing here,
roll up your mattress homie.
One man up, one man down.
You clean this out. I
clean this out one day.
You know what I mean?
Mandatory workout, Monday through Friday.
TV don't come on till about an hour.
Gotta read a book for an hour to two.
"Read a book for an hour?"
Oh my God.
Let me say, you say, something to him,
but you don't wanna do that.
I guarantee you,
you'll be like, oh, shit, yeah.
They do it to discipline yourself,
to learn something, to educate yourself,
not being stupid your whole life.
Them motherfuckers are doing life,
degrees, master degrees in their,
like what the fuck?
Man, I'm trying to tell the
mind is a beautiful thing.
I mean, it's so beautiful that,
if you waste it all on
drugs, drugs, drugs, drugs
then you're not going to
amount to nothing in life.
And if you do drugs, drugs, drugs
you can't pay your debt.
Why doing it in the first place?
First lead by example,
nipples lead by example.
But then you made us look bad.
It's like people get
the shit together now.
You know what I mean?
It's like, damn, and then,
when you have to face reality,
to take on a talon,
"Oh, officer, I'm in danger"!
And you posed to be a solid homie.
Oh my God.
It's sad.
But it's reality.
If you can't do this shit,
you can't do the time.
Don't do time at all, man.
It's like, you know,
today ...
It's ... it's ....
there's no more fucking unity,
everyone's falling apart.
Everyone's going, "Hey, go to SNY."
Fuck that.
That's my career, homie.
I'm not going to (inaudible)
That is a no-no.
And if you feel it's
the right to go to SNY,
then God be with you, homies.
Because, I can't do that.
I could never, never.
It's a fucked up way to live a life
knowing that you want to say you're active
and then you're S and Y,
Oh, that's bad. That's bad.
When I went to prison,
I walked on eggshells every fucking day,
hoping that I do not get stuck.
Don't bump into nobody.
Walk right.
Sneeze. Cover your mouth.
You know what I mean?
Morning? Buenos dias, Buenos dias.
Like damn, like being a little goody boy,
I would've been a nerd than be stupid,
and get stuck by somebody.
I don't want to get stuck.
But it's being shoe bankers.
You got to learn the word respect.
When you go to prison,
I guarantee you that.
when you come out, "how are you doing?"
Oh no, thank you.
"What the fuck?
That was a gang banger!"
"Hey, homie, the homie said..."
"Oh yeah."
I'm trying to tell you people today,
all the elders? What did we say?
Respect to all your elders.
Respect your elders.
But if you can't respect your elders,
"Hey, what's up, homie?"
Nah, I'm cool, dog.
You just done fucked up, coming up wrong.
Another way (speaking Spanish).
That's how you do it.
You do it with respect,
and believe me,
as for our race,
how you conduct yourself
and how you lead by example,
it shows you shine, homie.
It shows you stand tall,
for prison molded you to be strong.
Not to break you,
or let something get under your skin,
and make you be like,
(snaps) fuck you bitch!
Like what the fuck happened?
I mean, you know?
It molds you for discipline,
to learn from your
mistakes not to come back.
If I've been on six years, doing 17,
thank you, Jesus, that I'm still out here,
still fighting this battle every day.
Now with this COVID-19
shit, man, come on people,
wash your hands, cover your mouth, man.
You know?
And the ones in prison,
is more crazy for you guys.
Cause everyone's dropping like flies.
You know, the only way
we can beat this disease,
a mandatory work out.
Take care of yourself.
Don't let yourself go down.
You know what I'm saying?
In prison today,
money talks and bullshit walks.
I mean, you can have whatever you like.
I mean, wherever you're in prison
Trust me, I've seen it all myself.
But just like I said
just be that person
who you're going to do
for yourself, my boy.
Just do your time.
Go home to your family.
But don't ever think that, you know,
I gotta put in to get
where I want to be, homies.
Cause you know what?
You do it the easy way,
or do it the hard way,
but pay for the price of your consequences
knowing that what you want
to do, get your respect.
Oh, you got it all right.
Now you got to add charge.
It's all part of the game, homie.
You know what I mean?
One, two, three, one.
You're with the big boys,
bending all the rules now, homie.
You know, but when you're doing that
you're going to get the
respect at the same time.
You hope he could beat the
deal and break your case
and hopefully you can get
expunged or something.
But if not, then, it's more
time added to you fucking chart.
And there is no more going home.
I don't want to look at life.
And they got life, they do
like no remorse, no problem.
Like, I can't do that.
They get visits every
Sunday, boneyard visits.
Like damn!
No, no, I don't want that lifestyle.
But, I'm just saying, they got everything.
But that's their motive.
They have no choice but
to live that lifestyle.
If you have a date, man,
go home to your daughter,
to your wife, your kids,
to your auntie, grandma.
And, you know, take
care of the family, man.
Don't just say, "Oh, I'm not (inaudible),
Man, chill out, my boy, chill
out, chill out, chill out.
All this tattoo words
that you earned in prison,
let it be an example for yourself
that you have a nice
beautiful artwork ,homie,
that you earned it with respect.
And someone blessed you with this artwork,
you know, to, you know.
"Hey, who did that, homie?"
It was homeboys.
Oh man, I shut that.
Thank you, homie. You know what I mean?
You know, today in my life,
today I can only give a
message by just saying
where I've been today,
where I was at fucking 17 years ago,
but believe me, I would thank God
I would have one chance to be right here
in front of a camera, to
share my message to you guys.
To say, this is not a game.
If you are active and in a gang
more power to you, God be with you.
But if you're not, don't
half step in this game,
and be like, "I want to gang bang."
"No, I don't."
"I want to gang bang."
Make something legit, my boy.
Know what you want to do.
Cause believe me, when
you go to the big boys,
and they have shit,
"Oh my God, riots went up. Riot. Riot."
And you get stuck, and
you don't want to fight.
Ah, homie, I saw you,
you weren't going down.
"Yes, I was."
You're lying.
They're going to fucking kick
your ass for lying to them
because you didn't help them out.
"What?"
Come on, homie's scared straight.
Oh my God, just start throwing blows.
Do something, don't, just stand there.
Like damn! What the -?
Like, you know what
I'm telling you people,
if someone's watching you, dog,
and they say you weren't
part of the unity,
you were fucking chicken out.
You hide behind a fucking bunker and shit,
cause you don't want to get stabbed,
people getting killed.
Why do you sign up for this shit?
You know where you're going?
This is reality, my boy.
This is not a lifestyle for
everyone to fucking live.
If I had one chance, hey
motherfucker, a show of hands,
who wants to go home?
Every one wants to go home.
No one's wants to be inside there.
But if you made the mistake, man,
then, fucking A,
it's upon you to make the
better for yourself, my boy.
You got to fucking get
this shit started today,
not tomorrow, man.
You know, I got a cousin,
Polycon Bay, man, got 19 years.
He's getting out.
19 years and he only got what?
And I only got what? Maybe seven years?
Still got a whole stretch.
He (inaudible) Pelican Bay.
I want to go there,
but I didn't get there.
He's getting underwater
welding for ... for welding.
And he got a fucking certificate.
I'm fucking proud of him, man.
I'm proud of him because he's
making something of himself
not being stupid to say,
"I'm a shoe program. I'm
never getting out no more."
And, you know,
you go to where you want
to go in life today, homie.
If you want to be the
person you want to be.
But if you're still trying to figure out,
what you want to do with your life,
just know that, hey, if
you have a date, you know,
just take it for what
it is for today, my boy.
But there's dope game.
There's gang banging, prison
lifestyle, the politics.
It's a dirty game, homie.
It's a lot of fucking work
that you put yourself into.
But just know,
that the homie are there to
fucking mold you to be success,
to get the fuck out.
Wish they could be in
your shoes that one time.
"Damn, maybe I should be
in your shoes, homie."
"Hey, dog, don't come back, homie."
"Hey, stay off foot. Don't stay out."
They give you the calino,
They give you that love.
Not to come back.
I want to see you, there you're
more disappointed yourself.
Yeah, I'm more scared.
"Why's that?"
"I'm not supposed to be back here,
I'm supposed to be out there."
Yeah. What happened?
Fucked up again, huh?
I thought you learned your lesson, homie.
Apparently not.
They don't make it easy for you.
They make it more harder for you.
I mean, it's just..
It's a program, that we conduct ourselves
to either you fucking
make something yourself
or you don't make nothing at all.
Just because you're in prison,
doesn't mean I'm a failure.
Hey, I fucked up.
We all make mistakes.
No ones fucking perfect at at life,
but at least get your shit together.
Have your fucking balls and be like,
"Hey, you know what? I fucked up."
"Hey, you know what? I
made a mistake homie."
Now, but what?
"I didn't do it."
Stop going around the bush, homie.
Just a myth.
Be real with yourself first,
and say I fucked up, and you know what?
Do the time, do the crime, homie.
If you can't do the time, don't say,
"Mom, get me out of jail, Mom.
Put the mortgage in and all the ..."
Come on, man.
It's just, it's sad.
It really is.
But you know, for you youngsters
are still growing up,
and just keep your mind focused, homies.
Just stay working out, man.
Don't ever let no one fucking break you.
Don't ever let no one put you down.
You know.
You know, can't stop, won't stop.
Be down for whatever, man.
We always say stay in-front of the line.
You know.
You know, a closed mouth don't get fed.
You want to a thing, you ask.
Don't take nothing on your own remorse.
Don't be a five finger discount
because we can't stand thieves.
You know.
You know, just, you know,
keep that mouth shut,
ears open and just sit
back and watch the show.
You know, you will learn something,
I guarantee you that,
but there's always a stupid question
for a stupid answer.
There's never a "Hey, homes,
if you don't know anything tell me.
I'll guide you the right way, my boy.
You wanna work out with me?
Let's work out.
Come on, let's go. One, two, three, one.
What's that?
You helped me out, I help you out, homie.
And I'm going to show
you that working out."
Then you get a big crowd. A bigger crowd.
"What the fuck?"
Because you lead by example, my boy.
You show positive, even
though you're in prison
at least you show someone a good program,
that now about awfully,
"I'm slamming, I'm over
here sweating a shirt."
Now come on, now, man.
You know, today, homie,
people need some leadership.
People need some good
people by their side.
Not some phony ass people that ,
they don't even know,
fucking get you more time
for following this fool?
Think about, homies.
You know, today is 2021, man,
what you guys did last year, man?
Even though you're in
prison, or in juvenile hall,
make something better for yourself.
Always expect the unexpected.
Don't ever, ever sell yourself short, man.
Don't ever take second hand best
or we take a freaking first-class.
You know, you guys worked hard
for what you guys came for,
just because you're in fucking jail.
(smack)
Smack it on the fucking head.
You don't knock it off.
Stop, wake up, smell the coffee, man.
Bust down. Get your
money. Not coming back.
Not coming back.
What the fuck did I do?
What mistake did I make?
Damn it. Damn it. Damn, shit.
Learn from it.
Click.
I see the light, whatever the fuck it is
but get that shit through your head.
Know your mistakes.
Not to cut back.
And if it's drugs, give me a reason,
instead of an excuse and I'll listen.
Cause drug has played out already, dog.
A drug is but dumb-dumb.
If you can't do the drugs
then I don't know what
to tell you, my boy.
But I can't save everyone.
So, this message for all the youngsters,
the new generation.
Our prayers go out to you.
I pray that this message
comes to you in a real way.
Don't let no one break you.
Stay raised in all the get ready.
Stay strong.
Pray for me.
I pray for you.
God bless you guys.
Take care.